what's up gamers in this video I have a
free store much like I did in real life
where I let people go in a store and I
let them grab whatever they want and
they could keep it but in this video to
get to my free store you have to
complete one of the hardest obstacle
courses ever made we have 100 players
here in a super hard obstacle course and
every single one of them that finishes
this course gets whatever they want from
our free store so server drop the glass
let the Horde begin let's see who makes
it to the free store so they can get
free stuff Karl is also competing just
you know in dream bread time dream go
let's get this bacon yes Karl dream Co
is back at it again I'm pretty good at
parkour yeah you parkour around people
as they're trying to kill you and I'm
terrible at parkour well then you'll
probably die really early and lose
observer open the gates let's see who
can make it to the free store I finally
have my own skin dream ooh
what that's pretty cool oh god Karl are
you talking about skins
I've already betrayed the team people
are falling we lost someone
dude so many people are dying this is
only phase one no dream oh dream died
wait really
yeah he just died oh my god I got pushed
in I got look at you are you kidding you
thought I was gonna do he died before
you God people can bump you okay here's
here's my my motto is slow and Steady's
gonna win the race Karl's doing pretty
good actually he's taking it slow and
steady
hopefully Karl can for the first time in
his life when something in a video no
okay wait Chris is trying to mess with
me this is not even fair Jerry might
literally beat you that round well to be
fair you did distract me and then I did
get pushed off you know anyway come over
here and look at this skin I did look at
it you're gonna do this again get get in
the line server open round number two
my dreams eaten now he doesn't even care
I'm gonna take it slow and steady memens
Nadel ah okay
oh no I died right and I was doing so
good
oh the course is gonna get insanely hard
people are gonna be dying left and right
and as you can see dream has to start
from the very beginning since he just
died which is gonna be a lot of time
lost that was unfortunate I literally
was owning I'm at the next one I thought
the next one wait you're autonomous
level two oh my gosh
I'm a part of core master look at me go
hey dream we did it two gay together
world Rico go alright server drop the
third wall three two one oh don't spur
fect remember if you die here you go all
the way to the rack don't fall
dude dream is literally the prison
across it he doesn't even care
okay maybe I'm the first dream has
already made it across pretty good hey
Carl
pearl let me help you let me help you
whoa I told you it's gonna help you did
you see that coming no I actually
figured he wanted to help a friend out
god forbid I've made some good jumps
there I killed it I killed it that's
good yeah dreams like alright enough
about Carl look at all these people
they're kind of just stuck here to be
clear so that this is set in stone mean
dream decided if either of us win
because it's it's an equal possibility
for both of us Jeff if either of us win
both of us won yes that we have decided
I don't think you have the authority I
think we put you in charge there's some
more stragglers but we're not waiting
for them open the next barrier hey one
of those stragglers is Carl open it even
faster Chris I'm gonna kill them I'm
going to kill you
it's not even funny it's literally
impossible it's a little funny
can you drag in Raisin whitey raisin are
you in here yes hi what are your
thoughts of the videos so far um it's
really fun my hands are shaking like
crazy you know did we tell you why don't
you win I think like some Amazon thing
right yep at the end of this course is a
giant free store and you can have
whatever your heart desires if you get
there oh really
Wow as long as it's sold on Amazon in
under a thousand dollars open the next
gate I'm out I'm out of hunger am I
gonna get food oh my god yes what dream
Oh dream Phil oh I had no food I
couldn't sprint hey dream I'll wait for
you at the third level brows rigged I'm
all the way back at the beginning now
ring all raise it this kids doing good
Hydra V - is it first oh my gosh this
person was trying to push me all right
it looks like these kids are doing good
wait this is the final one to the
FreeStore okay okay all right
the FreeStore is on the horizon what
Jedi's game close to the FreeStore so is
coral oh that's unfortunate
you guys deleted so many blocks to ruin
me
we have quranic' umph look it has your
face on it that's your face on Carina
yeah look lovely it is that is your face
that's interesting how does that make
you feel violated
oh you're kidding me no dream you died
you nerd I add corinneandluke oh wait
who else is in here me so so what is
that over there let's free item shop it
is I hope you can make it I hope
something month alright I think we've
given enough time for people to catch up
I don't see any more any important
people yeah all of the important people
are here - I'm server drop the glass
what see this is a good one this is the
final one final oh I died
oh my god
dream did you die again yeah I died I'm
terrible terrible currently better than
dream heists my hands sweaty this kids
oh wait I he East MC are we going oh
he's going he's not they're not allowed
to go in the store yet I'm blocking it
off and block it off what about this kid
see if he makes it oh not only do you
have to get in the free store but you
have to get to the cashier's desk to
claim your prize oh oh he chickened out
oh no he knows the path let's see if he
does it goodbye poor guy
so we got tons of people coming but
we're not waiting we're going to the
free store hey contestants so I just
wanted to say the first 10 people to
make it to the cashier's desk in the
free store get to claim the free item
the first 10 okay there's already like
six people at the door but you got to
make it to the end of the store three
two one Oh dreams going dreams going of
course yes oh he's going yeah a dream
win it for us dreams got it dreams got
it
dream about to be the first one to
finish oh of course
all right dream dream come here come
here welcome to the cashier's desk I
will buy you whatever you want from
Amazon what do you want and I can I
donate it to charity
do you want to you want to donate it to
the other guy the coal yes so what do
you want on Amazon that cost less than a
thousand dollars oh my god I have no
idea I've been really put on the spot
here five four three
RTX twenty-eight ETI here's the pictures
text at your address and we will get it
to you thank you so much so all right
let's see if Karina has what it takes
oh nice nice nice oh nice Karina all
they have to do is make it past the
aisles of misery Oh No grete
no how is dream about to win two times
before yeah what else win one Timmy
he has the world record for Minecraft
all right
dream welcome back lava bring someone
else random in here are Zanna are you
here yes okay drink oh that was adorable
dream one and he wants to give you his
prize alright you have ten seconds what
do you want off Amazon that's under
$1000 um Intel like considered undress
it will ship it to you thank you for
coming up with TPD see what you do it oh
you doing a thing this guy's gonna make
it mr. B's let's see let's see I'm
watching its he gonna be our first
person that's not dream to finish
[Applause]
[Music]
dreamer another person made a yeah they
discover the secret tunnel I'm blocking
it off ja yes welcome to the world
thank you I would like to previous
please thank you 13 is getting $1,000
monitor I will quite literally have zero
desk space in the next week I assume
thank you alright maybe you should have
invested in a desk yes not our problem
our turn to read to cheat you yeah are
you in the folder I advise you use your
thousand dollars to buy a new mic are
you in the casket okay and he's getting
a monitor and a desk boom as you see
thank you for coming out to the free
store go jump in lava you could try to
win again if you want oh hey
alright you just won $1,000 what do you
want to spend it on our PlayStation for
her to PlayStation 4 PlayStation take
the decision of the gun PC or yes sure
right not a PC heck Scion you are
getting a brand-new $999 PC wait one
we're only taking one more winner
I hope these three people here know that
only one more person can win please but
I'm still too beginning only one more
person is it Corinna and Karina is our
final winner
silverfish Karina Kevin any of you in
the Cole yet yeah wait who's that I'm
Karina
probably under UPC okay another new PC
Kevin's being difficult not Jordan
silverfish is also will DM them will
figure out what they want take care of
it thank you guys so much for watching
congratulations everyone who won give me
a quick chat and we'll see you guys to
the next video thank you for coming out
to our free store